in this course you'll learn how to solve
10 very popular coding interview
problems
and you'll learn the theory behind the
solutions so you'll be better equipped
to solve other types of problems as well
welcome to the 10 popular coding
interview problems course 10 well-chosen
problems that cover different algorithms
and data structures topics to increase
your knowledge and prepare for
interviews
please try to solve before watching the
solution prepare yourself and see you in
the first lecture
welcome to this video where we will
solve the first problem of this course
valid anagram a quite easy problem
compared to next ones
we are given two strings s1 and s2 and
we are asked to check if they're
anagrams
two strings are anagrams if they're made
of the same characters with the same
frequency just in a different order
for example with the strings tender and
garden we take one of them we rearrange
its characters and we get the other one
how are we gonna solve this problem
we know that two strings are anagrams if
they have the same characters with the
same frequency so what we can do is to
calculate the frequency of each
character in s1 calculate the frequency
of each character in s2 and compare the
results
but what structure do we use to do so
we can use an array where each cell
represents the number of frequencies
they all start at zero then for each
character in the string we increment the
corresponding cell
this solution is suitable when the
alphabet is small when the number of
possible characters is not big
for example if the strings can only be
made of lowercase alphabetical letters
we'd need an array of 26 elements it's
fine
but it's not necessarily the case
they can contain all the characters
and we have thousands and thousands of
existing possible characters the array
would take a lot of time and space to
create it and traverse it
the best structure for our problem is
the hash table a structure that maps
unique keys to values
in our case the key will be the
character and the values number of
occurrences
for example if we have nameless and
salesman with nameless we get this hash
table and with salesman we get this one
here they have the same keys with the
same values so they're equal it means
that nameless and salesman are anagrams
in code we'll first check that both
strings have the same length because if
they're not it's impossible for them to
be anagrams
then we create our two hash tables and
we start traversing
for each character in s1 if the key is
already existing in frac 1 we just
increment else we create it and we set
its value to 1.
then for s2 same logic but with frec2
now that we filled them we check that
they have the same values for each k and
frac 1 if it doesn't exist in frack 2 or
for a quan of key isn't equal to
fracture of key we return false it means
that either the character of s1 doesn't
exist in s2 or they don't appear the
same number of times
after the loop if we didn't find any
difference we return true
and in python we don't even need to
write all this because we have a class
named countering collections module that
builds the table of occurrences just by
passing the string as an argument
and we can compare dictionaries with the
equality operator so in reality we'll
just return counter of s1 equal to
counter of s2
for the time complexity in the worst
case s1 and s2 have the same length
let's name it n
we'll traversing n characters at most
three times and switching inserting in a
hash table cos of one in average we'll
get of m plus o of m plus oop n which
gives an off and time complexity
and for the space complexity we have of
and for each table because they can
contain up to n keys each we get an off
and space complexity
we still have another solution to
discuss
you have to know that two anagrams have
the same lexicographically sorted string
for example with nameless and salesman
if we sort nameless we get a e e l m n s
s and with salesman same thing
so in the second solution we just sort
both strings and compare the results
in code after the equal length condition
we return sorted s1 is equal to sorted
s2 that's it
sorting a string of n characters cos of
analog and time we're doing it twice
plus for comparing we get an off analog
and time complexity
and for the space complexity we have off
and for the sorted result twice we'll
get an off and space complexity
we reach the end of this video we solve
the valid anagram problem
i hope that you understood both
solutions and see you in the next one
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the first and last
position problem
we are given a sorted array of integers
r and an integer target and we are asked
to find the index of the first and last
position of targeting r
if target can't be found in r we turn
minus one minus one
for example if r is two four five five
five five five seven nine nine and
target is 5 the output would be 2 6
because the first position of target is
2 and its last position is 6.
first of all because the array is sorted
all the elements with the same value
will be adjacent to each other for
example here all positions of the value
5 are consecutive
it means that the first possible
solution is to start traversing the
array from the beginning find the first
position of target and keep walking
until finding the lost position
with our example we have two four then
five we found the first position
we keep walking we have five five five
five this one is the last one we found
the end position return them
in code we start traversing indexes of r
and if r of i is equal to target it
means that we found the start position
now we keep walking while the next
element exists and is equal to target y
i plus 1 is smaller than length of r and
r of i plus 1 is equal to target we
increment i
after the while loop i now represents
the position of the last occurrence this
is why we return start i
and if the full loop ends without having
returned the result it means that we
didn't find target in r at all we return
minus one minus one
know that it's possible to have start
position equal to end position it
happens when there is only one
occurrence of targeting r
for the time complexity when target
exists we traverse the part before its
first position then its sequence of
occurrences and when it doesn't which
offers the whole array in both cases
whichever is at most add elements where
n is the number of elements of r we've
got a time complexity of of n
and a constant space complexity because
we're just using invariables
this solution uses linear search which
gave an off and time complexity
both the array is sorted so we can think
of using binary search
let's try to use binary search to find
the start position
with binary search we can find the
position of an element in a sorted array
but here we're not searching for any
position of target we're searching for
the first one
i is the first position of target if r
of i is equal to target obviously but
also r of i minus 1 has to be smaller
than target smaller because the array is
sorted
so we'll use binary switch normally but
to add a second condition before
returning mint
let's try it with our example left and
right started first and last element of
r as usual
man is left plus right divided by two we
get four here
it's true that our four is equal to
target but it's not enough r of 4 minus
1 is not smaller than target so mid is
not the starting position of target
but should we go to the left part or to
the right part now
r of mate is not greater than target so
the first position can only be in the
left part
we continue mid is now zero plus three
divided by two we get one
our phone is smaller than target so the
starting position can only be in the
right part
we continue it is now 2 plus 3 divided
by 2 which is 2.
r of mid is equal to target and r of mir
minus 1 is smaller than target so made
represents the first position of target
we return it
in code we can first have an early exit
condition for the case where the first
element is equal to target would
document know that 0 is the starting
position return 0.
by the way in solution space on binary
search put as much early exact
conditions as possible to handle edge
cases and avoid out of bounds problems
after it we initialize left and right at
0 and n minus 1 respectively 0 and n
minus 1 are the indexes of the first and
last element of r
now while left is smaller than or equal
to right we calculate mid index it's
left plus right divided by two
after it we have three cases the case
where both conditions are respected
where are made is equal to target and r
of minus one is more than target
it means that mid is a starting position
we return it
second case r of made is smaller than
target it means that we're still before
the starting position this is why we
take left to mid plus 1 to start again
in the right part
else it means that we exceeded the
consecutive sequence or we're inside it
but not at the beginning so start can
only be in the left part we take right
to mid minus 1.
and if the while loop didn't return the
result it means that target doesn't have
an existing r we return -1
now we found the start index but we
still need to find the end index
we can think of just walking starting
from start until we find the last
position of target
the bodies would ruin everything we did
because in the worst case we need to
traverse the whole array which results
in an off and time complexity same as
the first solution you guessed it to
find the end index we will also use
binary search
but the condition is a bit different
from the first time when searching for
the start position r of mid had to be
equal to target and r of mid minus 1
smaller than target
and for the end position r of med has to
be equal to target and r of mid plus 1
has to be greater than target
next element has to be greater because
it would mean that from the right we're
not in consecutive target elements
anymore so the actual position is the
last position of target
in code we just change a few things
the early exit condition occurs now when
the last element is equal to target it
means that the last position of target
is in the last index of r and minus 1
without clear return
then in the three cases the cases where
we return mid is when rf made is equal
to target and r of mid plus 1 is greater
than target
for the two remaining ones here one hour
of maid is greater than target then we
exceeded the consecutive sequence we go
to the left part right becomes mir minus
one
else it means that either way before the
consecutive sequence or we're inside it
but not at the end so end can only be in
the right part left becomes mid plus one
now we have our find start function we
have our find end function we can move
to the main solution function first of
all we have some early exit conditions
we can identify at least three cases
where we can't find target at all when
the array has no elements one target is
smaller than the first element and when
target is greater than the last element
in the last two ones because the array
is sorted we can deduce that target is
not equal to all other elements
if at least one of these conditions is
true without k return -1 -1
else we call fansa to get the start
position we call find and to find the
end position and we return start and
if target doesn't exist in r start and n
will have returned -1 both we still get
the expected result
for the time complexity we're using
binary search twice and binary search
has an offload and time complexity
because we keep dividing the input size
by two
two times offlock and gives an overlock
and time complexity
and for the space complexity we've got
of one because we're just using int
variables
before ending this lecture i want to
tell you that if you're not comfortable
with binary search you should really
work on it because it's a fundamental
algorithm technique that appears in many
problems like this one find peak first
bad version and many other ones
we reach the end of this lecture i hope
that you understood the solutions and
see you in the next one
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the kth largest
element problem
we are given an array of integers and an
integer k and we are asked to find the
kth largest element
for example if you have r equal to
429756713
[Music]
and k equal to four the output should be
six because the largest element is nine
the second largest is seven the third
largest is seven and the fourth largest
is six
the first possible solution that we may
think of is to remove the maximum
element k minus 1 times because after
doing so the next maximum represents the
kth largest element
for example with our array k is 4 so we
remove the maximum element 3 times
first iteration max is nine we remove it
second iteration max is seven we move it
third iteration max is seven we remove
it
now that we finished the three
iterations the maximum and remaining
elements is the 5th largest element of
the original array it's 6 here we return
it
in code we have a full loop that is
repeated k minus 1 times where we remove
the maximum element
after the loop we return max of r that's
it
for the time complexity searching for
the maximum cost of n where n is the
number of elements and removing it from
the array cos n is the worst case
because we may need to shift all the n
minus 1 elements
and our loop is repeated k minus 1 times
we have k minus 1 times 2 n
plus n for finding the final largest
element
in total we have k minus 1 times 2 n
plus n which is 2 times k times n minus
n which gives an o of k times and time
complexity where n is the number of
elements of r
i know that in reality during the
iterations n will decrease because we
have less and less elements but we get
the same time complexity
and for the space complexity we're not
using input size related variables we
have a constant space complexity
this solution is a bit slow let's move
to the next one
the idea of the second solution is to
start by sorting the array because by
doing so we know that the largest
element is at the last cell the second
largest element just before it the third
largest just before it and so on
with our array we sort it and k is four
so we turn the fourth element starting
from the end
in a general way we solve r and we turn
r of n minus k n minus k represents the
index of the kth element starting from
the end
for the time complexity we have of
analog and for sorting the array and r1
for accessing we've got an off analog
and time complexity
and for the space complexity it depends
on the space complexity of the sorting
function
this solution is way faster than the
first one except in some cases but we
still have another solution to discover
in the first solution we didn't have to
sort which is good but searching for the
maximum costs out at each iteration
which slows down the process
what if instead of and getting the
maximum cost lock and only yes it's
possible by using a priority queue
a priority queue is a queue where the
next element to be popped is not the
first one that entered but the one with
the highest priority and it's usually
implemented with a heap
if you don't know about heaps and
priority queues you should really watch
my youtube video on the subject you'll
find the link below or you can just
search for inside code heaps on youtube
and after building our priority queue
popping the next element costs of logan
only so we just have to pay the cost of
building the priority queue which is n
for example with our array this is what
our hip would look like you can see that
the element at the top is the greatest
one
we extract it and it costs offlock and
to rearrange notes
second iteration will extract the root
and it costs offlock and to rearrange to
maintain the order third iteration same
thing
now that we did the k minus 1 iterations
the next extracted node is the kth
largest element we return it here is 6.
in python we have the hip q module but
the problem is that it's implemented
with a min heap not a max heap so at the
top we'll find the smallest element not
the greatest to counter that we just
multiply values by -1 to reverse the
order
so we start by replacing r by minus lm
for each element in r
after doing so we hepify r to make it
respect the heap property
and now we're ready to start extracting
we extract from it k minus one
times after the loop we extract the last
time and return the result multiplied by
-1 obviously to get the original number
that was in r
for the time complexity we have n to
build a new array with reversed values
and to hippify it go check the video to
know why and then we have k minus 1
iterations
each iteration costs offload and to
extract
after the loop we have offload and to
extract one more time
in total we have two n plus k minus one
times log n plus log n which is two n
plus k log n which gives a time
complexity of of m plus k log n which is
a bit better than the one of the
previous solution because k can't exceed
n
well this solution starts giving
interesting time performance difference
only when n is huge and k small because
when k is close to n of n plus k log n
is close to o of analog n the time
context of the previous solution but
when k is close to zero
o of m plus k log n is close to of n
and for the space complexity we have and
for the priority queue we get an off and
space complexity
we reached the end of this video i hope
that you understood the three solutions
and see you in the next one
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the symmetric tree
problem
we have a binary tree and we want to see
if it's symmetric in other words if it's
a mirror of itself
for example this tree is symmetric
because if we take its left part reverse
it we get its right powered
and vice versa if we take its right part
we reverse it we got his left part
but this one is not symmetric for
example if we reverse its left part we
don't get the right part
ok how to solve this problem
to check if it is symmetric what we
really need to check is that left and
right subtrees are symmetric to each
other we will focus on that
you need to know that for tree problems
the solution is usually done recursively
we process the root then we call the
function on both subtrees and we combine
the results
for example to get the sum of elements
of a binary tree we have the value of
the root then we recursively call the
function on both subtrees to get the sum
of their elements after doing so we
return root value plus sum of laptop 3
plus sum of right subtree
this way of traversing is called depth
first search and it's how we solve the
majority of three problems
let's go back to our problem we have two
trees root one and root two and we want
to check if they're symmetric to each
other
first case both trees are empty in that
case we return true because there's
still some metrics to each other there
is nothing that breaks the condition
second case one tree exists but the
other one doesn't in that case would
ugly the dues that are not symmetric
because the node of the tree that exists
doesn't even exist in the other one it's
empty return false
third case both trees exist but the
roots don't have the same value here
also they're not symmetric because in
symmetric trees the roots must have the
same value because when we reverse a
tree the root position doesn't change
and last case both trees exist and they
have the same root value in this case we
still can say that there's a metric
because okay the roots have the same
value but we still need to check their
subtrees having the same root value is
not enough to say that they're symmetric
and if we take two symmetric trees we
can notice that they have the same root
value though the left subtree of the
first one is symmetric to the right
subject of the second one and that the
right subject of the first one is
symmetric to the left subject of the
second one
we verify that root values are equal so
we need to check the remaining two
conditions
and how are we gonna do so we're gonna
do so recursively
because if you think about it we're
building a function that checks if two
binary trees are symmetric which is
exactly what we need this is why we will
use the same function
it may sound hard to understand but this
is what recursion about a function
calling itself
if you're not familiar with recursion
you should really have a look at it
before continuing this course because we
will use it again in a further problem
if you want to learn a question you
can't check the course i made on the
subject it's a complete and well
appreciated course that will let you be
comfortable with your question
let's go back to our problem
we said that we used the function we're
making we said that we use the function
we're making we call it on root1.left
and root2.right we call it on
root1.right and root2.left and we check
that both calls return true it means
that both conditions are verified that
the left subject of root 1 is symmetric
to the right subtract root 2 and that
the right subject of root 1 is symmetric
to the left subject of root 2.
let's quickly see an example
we want to check if this tree is
symmetric so we check if its subtrees
are symmetric to each other
they have the same root value so we
check left subtree of root one with
right subtract root two
same root value we check left subject of
root 1 with right subtract root 2.
same root value we check left and right
same root value and their children are
both null they will return true
same root value in symmetric children
all conditions are respected it returns
true
now right subject of root one with left
subject root two they have the same root
value
their children are both null both closer
to and true all conditions are respected
the color turns true
back to here all conditions are
respected the call returns true
now writes up traffic route 1 with left
subject of route 2.
they don't have the same root value the
caller turns false
not all conditions are respected the
call returns false
we don't even need to check the second
call because we already have a
non-respected condition the call returns
false
the initial call return false so our
tree is not symmetric
in code
let's first make our r symmetric
function it takes two trees as parameter
root one and root two
first case both don't exist without
clear turn true
second case one of them exists but the
other one doesn't and third case they
have a different root value
in both of these cases the trees are not
symmetric so return false
we'll write if root 1 is none is not
equal to root 2 is known or root 1.val
is not equal to root 2.val we return
false
and now in the last case both trees
exist and have the same root value we
still need to check subtrees
we check that root1.left is symmetric to
root to detroit and that root1.right is
symmetric to root2.left we do so by
recursively calling the function twice
once with root1.left and root2.right and
once with root1.right and root2.left
both of them need to return true so
return the results combined with the and
operator
and now when our main solution function
is symmetric we first check that the
input tree exists because if it doesn't
we can directly return true an empty
tree symmetric
else we check that its subtrees are
symmetric to each other with the
function we made now we return r
symmetric root dot left and root dot
right that's it
for the time complexity we're just
performing a depth first search
traversal of the input tree and the fs
costs of anti more n is the number of
nodes
and for the space complexity a symmetric
tree has to be balanced and the
coolstack saw is needed by a recursive
function that traverses a balanced
binary tree is an offload add will get
an offload and space complexity
that's it for this lecture we've seen an
interesting problem on trees i hope that
you've been able to understand the
solution see you in the next lecture
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the generate
parenthesis problem a problem that we
will solve using backtracking
by the way in this course i try to
include problems on different patterns
binary search hash table backtracking
depth first search and so on
but one problem in each is not enough
this is why you need to study more
problems for that
i suggest you to have a look at my 50
popular coding interview problems course
it contains 50 problems different from
the ones in this course about many data
structures and algorithmic techniques
you can have a look at the curriculum
and reviews on the main page
anyway let's go back to our problem we
are given an integer n and we are asked
to generate all valid combinations of n
pairs of parenthesis for example with n
equal to 3 here are all the valid
combinations
first of all what does a valid
combination mean and how to check if a
combination is valid a combination that
contains one type of parenthesis is
valid if every opening parenthesis has
its closing parenthesis and it doesn't
have a closing parenthesis without
having an unused opening parenthesis
before it
let's see some examples
this combination is invalid because
these opening parenthesis don't have
closing parenthesis the syntax isn't
valid
second example this combination is
invalid because we have a closing
parenthesis without an unused opening
parenthesis before it
last example this one is valid because
each opening parenthesis has its closing
one and there is no closing parenthesis
without an unused opening one before it
now how to check if a combination is
valid to do so we can maintain a stack
where we push when we found an opening
parenthesis and we pop when you find the
closing one
the condition is that we don't try to
pop from the stack when it's empty and
the stack has to be empty after we
finish traversing the combination
trying to pop from the stack when is
empty means that we have a closing
parenthesis without an available opening
one before it
all ones what we found before have been
popped by all their closing parentheses
and the second condition is that the
stock must be empty at the end because
still having elements in the stack after
traversing means that we have opening
parenthesis that didn't gather closing
one yet
in both cases the combination is not
valid
and because we have only one type of
parenthesis round ones we don't even
need the stack we can just use a
variable div that represents the
difference between the number of opening
parenthesis and the number of closing
ones
it has to be zero at the end and if it
becomes negative during the process then
it's not valid
okay but what's the relation with
backtracking in this problem we're not
asked to check if a combination is valid
we're asked to generate all valid
combinations of n pairs
and we use backtracking because at each
step of building the combination we have
two possibilities adding and opening
parenthesis and adding a closing one
and because we want all combinations we
try them both because we get new ones
when we add an opening one and all the
ones when we add a closing one
also in backtracking we can have a
condition where we backtrack without
continuing it's when we know that the
actual branch won't lead us to a valid
solution
in our case it's when death becomes
negative it means that the combination
we built until now isn't valid it's
useless to continue building it we know
that it won't give us a valid
combination anyway
let's see an example
with n equal to 3 we'll get this
recursion tree
if you're wondering why and starts at 6
it's because the n given as input
represents the number of pairs and in n
pairs we have 2 and parenthesis so we
multiply by 2 because we're adding one
parenthesis by level when we go to the
left we add an opening one in increment
diff and when we go to the right we add
a closing one and decrement diff
we can notice that we have branches that
have been stopped earlier those are
branches where div becomes negative as
soon as diff becomes negative we stop
also even with branches that created the
combination of n pairs we don't take all
of them we take only those where dif is
equal to zero remember the validity
condition
so at the end here are the combinations
that get added to our combinations array
in code we start by creating a recursive
function rack that will fill the
combination's array
it takes us parameters n the number of
remaining parenthesis to add
diff the difference between opening and
closing brackets
calm the actual combination that we're
building and comps the array of
combinations the one that we're
searching for in our problem
the first base case is when diff becomes
negative here we darkly backtrack we
darkly return to go back to the previous
call
the second base case is when we've been
able to add all the parentheses we've
been able to build a combination
but in this case we don't automatically
add it to our comps array we first check
if diff is equal to zero remember the
condition
so if diff is 0 we draw the parenthesis
of our combination to form a string and
we add it to our valid combinations
array
else we have the recursive case
we said that we have two possibilities
adding and opening parenthesis and
adding a closing one
therefore we will have two recursive
calls for the first one we add an
opening parenthesis to our combination
then when we call n becomes n minus 1
because we have one less parenthesis to
add
and div becomes div 1 because remember
that we add 1 when we add an opening
parenthesis
after the call we remove the opening one
we added to put a closing one
after doing so we call the function
again but this time diff becomes d minus
one remember that we subtract one when
we add a closing parenthesis
and after the call we remove the
parenthesis we added to backtrack to the
previous call
and we made our function
by the way we can ever optimize a little
bit by darkly returning if d is greater
than n because if it's the case it means
that we don't have enough remaining
parenthesis to close all our opening
parenthesis d is greater than n so we
just return
if you're confused about what's
happening here have a look again another
recursion tree and most importantly you
should learn more about recursion and
backtracking the method we're using here
to generate all possible combinations
it's common to a lot of problems you
should really be comfortable with it
and now in the main solution function we
first create an array comps where we
will put our valid combinations and we
call our recursive function to fill it
but the tricky part here is that we pass
two times n as an argument not n because
the n given as input represents the
number of pairs not the number of
parentheses
and a pair is made of two parentheses so
we pass two times n
our combinations will be of length two
times n
after filling comes we just return it
for the time complexity in the worst
case when n is zero we have a cost of n
to draw the parenthesis we write t of
zero is equal to n
and in the recursive case and again
we're moving from the combination cost
of one but we have two calls where the
input size gets reduced by one and is
becoming n minus 1.
in total t of n is equal to 2 times c of
n minus 1 plus 1.
now we keep replacing t of n is equal to
2 times t of n minus 1 plus 1 so t of n
minus 1 is equal to 2 times t of n minus
2 plus 1. we replace
we simplify and we get 4 times t of n
minus 2 plus 3.
we replace again t of n minus 2 is 2
times 2 of n minus 3 plus 1. we replace
we simplify and we get eight times t of
n minus three plus seven
this recurrence relation is a common one
we can already notice the general form
its t of n is equal to two power k times
t of n minus k plus two power k minus
one
we have the value of t of zero so we
need to find the value of k to go to t
of zero
and minus k equal to zero so k is equal
to n
where plus k by n we get t of n is equal
to two power n times t of zero plus two
power n minus one
we know that t of zero is n we replace
we get t of n is equal to two power n
times n plus two power and minus one
which gives an o of n times 2 power and
time complexity
note that here n represents the length
of the combination which is 2 times the
number of pairs given as input
also n times 2 power n is not the exact
power the number of operations will be
less than that due to branches where we
backtrack earlier o n times 2 power n
would be the exact bound if we had no
condition on our combinations
if you don't know the technique i used
to find the time complexity over this
recursive function it's called the
substitution method it's an important
technique to know you should learn about
it
and for the space complexity we have m
plus 1 for the cossack size the length
of the longest branch in the recursion
tree but we also need to count the
required space to store the combinations
the length of a combination is at and it
has two possible characters so we have
two power and possible
and
combinations
length of each one of them is n so we
need n times 2 power and space to store
them
we get o of n times 2 power and a space
complexity
but not all of them are valid we will
need way less than n times 2 power n n
times 2 power n is just an upper bound
in reality the required space for
combinations is n times the number of
elements after filling the comps array
we reached the end of this lecture i
hope that you understood this
backtracking solution and see you in the
next one
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the gas station
problem we are given a circular list of
gas stations where we can go from a
station i to the station i plus one and
the last one goes back to the first one
and we are asked to find the index of
the station from where we start to be
able to traverse all the stations and go
back to the initial one without running
out of gas
note that we can only move forward the
gas tank starts empty gas of i
represents the amount of gas at the
station i cost of i represents the cost
to go from the station i to the next one
the answer is guaranteed to be unique
and if the station we're switching for
doesn't exist we turn -1
we deduce that there will be at most one
station from where we can traverse and
be able to go back
for example if we have these 10 stations
the output is 8 because when we start
from station 8 we can go back to it
without running out of gas
we start with no gas as mentioned in the
problem we add 4 gas of station 8 and we
pay 1 to move to the next station we add
5 guests of station 9 and we pay 2 to
move to the next station
we add 1 and pay 5 we add 5 and pay 2 we
add 3 and pay 2 we add 3 and pay 8 we
add 5 and pay 2 we add 3 and pay 4 we
add 1 and pay 2 we add 3 and pay 5 and
we've been able to go back to station 8.
you could see that the amount of gas
never became negative
which is not the case for all the
stations for example with station 1 we
add 5 and pay 2 we add 3 and pay 2 we
add 3 and here if we pay the 8 to move
to the next station the amount of gas
becomes negative which means that we
can't continue the station we started
from is not the right one
let's solve this problem a bruteful
solution that darkly comes in our mind
is to simply simulate what happens with
every station and if we find one that
respects the condition we return its
index
let's try it with our example with the
first one we add 1 we pay 5 and the cost
becomes negative darkly eliminated
next one we add five and pay two we add
three and pay two we add three and pay
eight and the amount of remaining gas
became negative not this one
next one we add three and pay two we add
three and pay eight and remaining became
negative
next one we add three and pay eight
remaining became negative
next one we add five and pay two we have
three and pay four we add one and pay
two we add three and pay five and
remaining became negative not this one
next one we add three and pay four
negative next one we add one and pay two
negative next one we add three and pay
five negative
next one we have plus four minus one
plus five minus two
plus one minus five plus five minus two
plus three minus two plus three minus
eight plus five minus two plus three
minus four plus one minus two plus three
minus five and we've been able to go
back to the station from where we
started we darkly return it because we
know that the answer is unique
in code we create a function that takes
us parameters the array gas the array
cost and the index of the station from
where we start
the goal of this function is to tell us
if we can finish the cycle by starting
from the station start
we first need a variable remaining that
stores the remaining amount of gas we
also need the variable to store our
actual position
our initial position is the station from
where we start so initialize i at start
and we also need a boolean variable
started to know if we started working
yet or not we need this variable in our
loop condition
we need to keep looping until we go back
to start we write while i isn't equal to
start or not started
here not started is important because if
we don't use it we won't even enter the
loop remember that i is initialized at
start so i and start are equal
we want them to be equal but after
traversing the cycle not now this is why
we need the variable started to know if
we're in the case where i is equal to
start because we didn't start yet or
because we traverse the cycle and i went
back to start
let's continue inside the loop we set
started to true because we started
then we update remaining we said that at
the station i we add the amount of gas
in it and we pay the cost to move to the
next one so we add gus of i and subtract
cost of i
after doing that if remaining becomes
negative it means that we couldn't go
back to start we don't have enough gas
we return false else we move to the next
station
the next station is usual at i plus 1
but we need to add modulus the number of
stations to handle the case where we're
at the last station i becomes i plus 1
and models and it goes back to zero
we write i becomes i plus one modulus
the number of stations
and if we finish the loop it means that
we've been able to go back to start
return true
now in our main solution function we
just try the function we made on each
station as we did in the example and we
return the actual station as soon as the
function returns true
and if the function fails with all
stations we return -1.
for the time complexity because the
answer is unique a possible worst case
is this one
because by starting from station zero we
traverse n stations before getting a
negative amount from station one we
traverse n minus 1 from station 2 which
reverses n minus 2 and so on
we get the sum n plus n minus 1 plus n
minus 2 and so on until 1.
after simplifying we found that it's an
off n squared we get an off n squared
time complexity
add a constant space complexity because
we're not using input size related
variables
of n squared is slow for this problem
we're getting off n squared because for
each station we're traversing again
almost all the stations let's see how to
optimize it
the main thing that you need to
understand for the second solution is
that if we start from a station at the
index start and reach a negative amount
of the station i
then all stations between start and i
inclusive are not valid we don't need to
try them we darkly jump to iplus one
let me tell you why
we have the case where gas of start is
smaller than cost of start here the loop
stops darkly because remaining becomes
negative it stops at start so there are
no other stations involved nothing to
talk about here
but when gas of start is greater than or
equal to cost of start the loop moves to
all the stations it can traverse a bunch
of stations before remaining becomes
negative
for example here when we start at
station 4 remaining becomes negative at
index 7. it means that stations 4 5 6
and 7 are all invalid we start again
from i plus one eight
but why
guess of start is greater than or equal
to cost of start in our case the
difference is three
and this three is considered as an
advantage over starting from next
stations it's like a bonus by starting
from station 4 we have 3 more gas than
starting from the next one station 5.
and even with that bonus we didn't have
enough gas to do a full cycle we stopped
at station 7.
even with that bonus we couldn't go over
station seven so how do you want to go
over it without that bonus
it's like you have five hundred dollars
and they aren't enough to buy a
particular pc then you say
these 500 dollars weren't enough i'll
try with 400s maybe they will be enough
it's illogical
and this is why when remaining becomes
negative we don't try again from the
station that comes after the one where
we started we skip all the ones we
traversed we start again from i plus one
with our example we start from the
beginning remaining becomes negative we
start from i plus one
we add five and we pay two remaining
becomes three we add three we pay two
remaining becomes 4 we add 3 we pay 8
remaining becomes -1 negative
what we're gonna do now is to darkly
start again from here without trying
again from stations two three
we add value pay two remaining becomes
three we have three we pay for remaining
becomes two we add one we pay two
remaining becomes one we at three we
play five remaining becomes minus one
negative
once again we'll directly start again
from i plus one
we add four we pay one remaining becomes
three we add five we pay two remaining
becomes six
and we finish traversing the array the
candidate is station eight
but it doesn't mean that it can do a
full cycle it just means that we can
reach the end of the array without
reaching a negative amount of gas we
didn't check the part before it
this is why i said candidate it's a
potential vowel station we don't know
yet
to say that a candidate station is valid
by starting from there remaining must
never become negative when traversing
the path from candidate to the end
but also when traversing the path from
the beginning of the array to candidate
exclusive
the first part of the cycle is what we
verified during the traversal and for
the second part of the cycle we just
calculate the sum of gas from 0 to
candidate minus the sum of cost from 0
to candidate the result represents the
remaining gas after traversing that part
if by adding it to remaining the result
stays positive then candidate is a valid
station else we have no value station
for example here the sum of gas from 0
to candidate exclusive is 24 and the sum
of cost from 0 to candidate exclusive is
30. the difference is 1 is 6.
what remains from candidate to the end
is 6 what remains in the pot before
candidate is -6 by adding them together
we get 0 which is positive so candidate
is the value station
question what if we got a negative
result here then would darkly return -1
because there is no valid stations
but what if the value station comes
after the candidate it's impossible once
again the station from where we started
candidate has an advantage over next
stations we know that gas of candidate
is greater than or equal to cost of
candidate
so even if with that bonus we get a
negative remaining amount of gas it will
also be the case for next stations
let's jump to the code to understand all
of this remaining starts at zero and
same thing for candidate because at the
beginning we assume that the first
station is the candidate the potential
valley station
now we start traversing stations for
each station we update remaining gas we
add gas of i and subtract cost of i
and if remaining becomes negative we
said that we start again from ipos1 it
becomes a new candidate and remaining
becomes zero because we will start again
after the loop we calculate remaining
gaps of the part before candidate the
sum of gas minus the sum of costs of the
part from 0 to candidate exclusive
now we have 3 possible cases we have the
case where candidate is equal to n it
means that we reach the end of the array
without finding a potential station
no station made it to the end of the
array we return -1
second case we have a candidate but when
adding prep remaining we found the
negative result it means that it stopped
somewhere in the path from 0 to
candidate we return -1
and third case we have a candidate and
remaining plus prime remaining is not
negative so candidate is the value
station from where we start to be able
to do a full cycle we return it
in code if candidates is equal to length
of gas the number of stations or
remaining plus per remaining is smaller
than zero will return -1 else we return
candidate
we can even keep track of priv remaining
in the first loop to avoid traversing
again to calculate the sums
for the time complexity we just have a
loop that does any iterations all other
operations are in of one we get an oauth
and time complexity where n is the
number of stations much better than of n
squared
and a constant space complexity because
we're not using input size related
variables
basically in the solution we search for
the candidate the station that made it
to the end of the array without reaching
a negative amount of gas
then we check if it still bears up when
traversing remaining stations
those in the path from the beginning of
the array until going back to it
we reached the end of this video i hope
that you understood the optimal solution
and see you in the next one
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the course
schedule problem we have n courses
labeled from 0 to n minus 1 in classic
that we need to take
but some of them are prerequisites to
other we cannot take a course before
taking the other one
and we have to determine if it's
possible to finish all the courses
so we are given an integer n
representing the number of courses and
an array prerequisites where
prerequisites of i is equal to a b means
that you first need to take the course b
before taking the course a
for example if we have this input the
output should be false because to take
course 3 we must have taken course 0 and
to take course 0 must have taken course
1 and to take course 1 we must have
taken course 3.
which is impossible it's like we have a
dependency cycle this is why we cannot
finish all the courses return false
but with this input the output is true
we can take course 0 then course 3 then
course 1 then course 5 then course 2
then course 4 each course will have its
prerequisites satisfied when taking it
how to solve this problem here we have
elements courses and relationships
between them a course being a
prerequisite of another course
and every time you face this situation
having elements and relationships
between them you should think of using a
graph
i'm not saying that it will always give
the best solution but even if it doesn't
it will at least give you a way to
visualize the problem with vertices and
links between them
in our case the vertices represent
courses and edges represent dependencies
and add from u to v means that we first
need to take the course u before being
able to take the course v
ok now we build our graph we got a
directed graph what we will do with it
our goal now is to search for a
dependency cycle if we find one it means
that it's impossible to finish all the
courses return false
else if we don't find one at all it
means that it's possible to finish them
all return true
basically we're searching for a cycle in
a directed graph
in a linked list a classic way to check
if there is a cycle is to traverse a
linked list while saving visited nodes
and if we step on a node that we've
visited before it means that there is a
cycle
we can think of applying the same logic
for graph which are works with depth
first search for example while using a
set of visited notes and if we step on a
node that has already been visited it
means that we have a cycle returned
false
by the way if you don't know about depth
first search it's a way of traversing
trees and graphs by diving deep into a
direction until we can't move forward
anymore go back try another way and so
on
i made a youtube video about the subject
that you can watch you need to know
about dfs before continuing this video
it's a prerequisite intended pun
but this strategy doesn't always work
here is a counter example
we have this graph let's start
traversing we start for example from 2
we put it in visit it we move to 0 we
put it in visit it we move to 3 we put
it in visit it
this one has no outgoing address we
backtrack
this one has no remaining neighbors to
traverse we backtrack
from here we move to the second neighbor
one we put it in visit it we'll move to
four we put it in visited then from here
we move to three and it's already in
visited so our strategy would return
false
which is wrong because we can totally
finish all the courses here we can start
with two then zero then three then one
then four all prerequisites are
respected
what's the solution then well let me
first talk about topological sword
we have a directed graph where vertices
represent tasks and an add from u to v
means that u is a prerequisite of v
topological sort is the process of
finding a linear ordering of vertices
such that each vertex comes after its
prerequisites in other words for each
add from you to v
v must come after you in the ordering
for example for this graph here is a
valid ordering
note that a valid ordering is not always
unique it's possible to find all the
orderings that satisfy the condition
but topological sort is not always
possible it's not possible when the
graph contains a cycle like this one
b is a prerequisite of c c is a
prerequisite of d
d is a prerequisite of e and e is a
prerequisite of b so we have no way to
order them
fortunately while performing the
topological sword we can detect the
existence of a cycle if it happens we
just stop and say that we cannot have a
valid ordering of vertices
and it's exactly what we want to do in
our problem we have courses some of them
are prerequisites to other ones and we
want to know if we can take all the
courses in all the terms if a valid
ordering exists
therefore we will use topological sword
and if during the process we found the
cycle we return false otherwise we turn
through because it means that we've been
able to make an ordering
okay but how does topological sort work
a possible way to implement apological
sword is depth first search
let's for example start from this vertex
we put it on the path stack
the path stack contains the vertices of
the actual path
b is its neighbor we go to it and we put
it on the path stack
is its neighbor we go to it and we put
it on the path stack
it is its neighbor we go to it and we
put it on the path stack
now h has no neighbors it means that we
can safely put it in our ordering
because there are no vertices that have
to come after it it's a prerequisite of
no one
we put it in the order stack and we
backtrack to the previous node
next neighbor is i we go to it and we
put it on the path stack same again it
has no neighbors we remove it from path
stack and put it on order stack and we
backtrack
next neighbor is f we go to it j is a
neighbor we go to it it has no neighbors
we remove it from path stack we put it
on order stack and we backtrack
next neighbor is i but it's already
visited
it has no more unvisited neighbors so
all vertices that have to come after it
in the ordering are visited we can
safely put this one and we backtrack
this one also has no more unvisited
neighbors we can put it in order stack
and we
backtrack and the process continues like
that until we traverse the whole graph
at the end we get this ordering reverse
it to get the order from the beginning
to the end not the opposite
in code our dfs function takes us
parameters to graph the vertex from
where we start the path stack the older
stack and the set of visited notes
we start by adding our vertex to the
path stack just when we start traversing
it then for each unvisited neighbor we
first added to visit it and we call the
fs with it as an argument to traverse it
after doing so for all the neighbors we
can safely put the actual vertex on the
order stack we pop it from path stack
and give it to order stack
and in our main top sort function it
takes as an argument the adjacency list
of our graph
it creates the visited set the path
stack the order stack then it visits
each unvisited vertex with dfs
after doing so the other stack is filled
returns reverse to get the ordering from
the first vertex to the last one not the
opposite
and starting from this algorithm we
can't add instructions to detect cycle
we find the cycle when we find the back
edge an edge that goes from vertex u to
a vertex v where v is already in the
path stack
like here we have a b c d e then e has b
as a neighbor which is already on the
path stack this graph contains a cycle b
and e depends on each other
in code our dfs function will now be a
boolean function it returns if yes or no
we've been able to make an ordering
what we add is that before moving to a
neighbor we check if it's not already in
the stack if it's the case we'd like to
return false we can't make a valid
ordering
also if traversing enable returns false
it means that we found the cycle when
going from there
this is why if the recursive code turns
false we also return false here
and if we've been able to traverse
neighbors without getting a negative
result return true we could make an
ordering
know that to optimize checking for the
existence of the actual vertex in the
stack it's better to use a set instead
of a list searching in a set is an of
one time in average
path stack now is of typeset at the
beginning we add our vertex to it after
the loop we move it and we add it to all
the stack
and in our main solution function we
first need to build the graph because as
input we have the number of courses and
the list of prerequisites not the
adjacency list
to build the adjacency list we know the
number of vertices so we create an array
of n empty arrays each one will contain
neighbors of the course i
now each other's prerequisites
the problem says that prerequisite of
one has to come before prerequisite of
zero so we create an add from
prerequisite of one to prerequisite of
zero in other words we add prerequisite
of zero to neighbors of prerequisite of
one
now that we've built the adjacency list
we can start traversing but before we
create the visited set the path stack
which is also a set and the order stack
then for each unvisited course we added
to visit it and if calling dfs with it
returns false it means that we couldn't
build the order we found the cycle so
return false we can't study all the
courses
and if the loop doesn't return false it
means that we could find an ordering we
can study all the courses return true
and we've been able to solve our problem
for the time complexity reduce
performing depth-first search on a graph
and the time complexity of dfs is off
length of v plus length of e while
length of v is the number of vertices
and length of e the number of edges
here the number of vertices is the
number of courses and and the number of
edges is m the length of prerequisites
list we've got an off amp plus and time
complexity
and for the space complexity we have the
space for the adjacency list length of v
plus length of e the space for the
visited set length of v the space for
the path stack and the order stack
length of v and the space for the call
stack length of v
in total we get 4 times length of v plus
length of e which is an off length of v
plus length of e which is of n plus m
note that you may find a similar
solution but with colors each vertex can
have the color white gray or black
compared to our solution what means
unvisited gray means visited and in the
past stack and black means visited and
not in the past second anymore we've put
it in the order
and if we find the neighbor that is gray
it means that it's in the actual path
and we found it again so we have a cycle
return false
now we implemented topological sort with
depth first search but we can also
implement it with breadth first search
let me show you how
if you don't know about breadth first
search i made a youtube video about it i
recommend you to watch it before
continuing this one
the general idea of our second solution
is to split our directed graph into
levels in the first level we have
vertices that have no prerequisites
we can darkly start studying them
once we finish we can remove them from
the graph
by removing them from the graph some
vertices won't have prerequisites
anymore because their prerequisites were
courses we just started and they're
satisfied
and these vertices represent the second
level we put them in our ordering and we
remove them
after removing them some vertices won't
have prerequisites anymore they
represent the third level we put them in
our ordering and we remove them
and the process continues like that
until we have no more vertices
but removing vertices from a graph costs
some time because we need to update the
adjacency list
instead we'll keep track of the in
degree of each vertex and when we
traverse a vertex we decrement the
indegree of all these neighbors
the in degree of a vertex is the number
of edges that are entering it for
example the in degree of this vertex is
two
so when we remove a vertex that is going
to it we decrement the in degree
and if the indegree of a vertex becomes
zero it means that all its prerequisites
are satisfied we can traverse it we put
it in the queue
with this graph we count the indegree of
each vertex we search for vertices with
an in degree of 0 we put them in the
queue and we apply a classic bfs
traversal
the difference is that when we pop a
note from the queue we start by putting
it in the ordering array because it has
no remaining prerequisites
also when we traverse a neighbor we
decrement it in degree and if it becomes
zero we put it in the queue
last thing we don't need a visited set
because we're not putting a vertex in
the queue until we finish traversing all
vertices that are going to it so we
don't have the risk of traversing a
vertex again
with this graph this is what happens
in code we create an array of n empty
arrays as we did with dfs
but we also add an array of n zeros to
store the indegree of each vertex
now when filling the adjacency list we
also increment in degree of prerequisite
of zero because prerequisite of zero is
the vertex where the edge enters so
increment it in degree
now we'll create an array where we will
put our ordering and a queue the queue
initially contains vertices host in
degree zero
after it we start traversing while the
queue still contains elements we pop a
vertex we add it to ordering because it
has no unsatisfied prerequisites and we
traverse its neighbors
for each neighbor we decrement it in
degree and if it becomes zero we enqueue
it as explained earlier
after the loop the order array is now
filled we return it this time we don't
need to reverse it because we started by
putting vertices of level 0 then 1 and
so on
with this topological sort algorithm we
can also detect cycles when the graph
contains cycles what happens is that at
some point of the process we will have
no more vertices with an indegree of 0
which means that nothing will be
inserted in the queue the process stops
and the order array will contain less
than the total number of vertices we
will deduce that the process couldn't
continue because there is a cycle
and in our problem we just want to know
if we can make an ordering or not this
is why after the loop we will just
compare the length of the order array
with n the number of courses
if they're equal the algorithm returns
true else it returns false
so we keep the same code we'll just
change the return statement written
length of order equal to n
the time complexity we're just applying
breadth first search which has an off
length of v plus length of a time
complexity of m plus m in our problem
and for the space complexity we have
length of v plus length of a for the
adjacency list length of v for the
in-degree array and length of v for the
q and the order array
three times length of v plus length of e
gives off length of v plus length of e
which is of m plus m in our problem we
get an off and plus m space complexity
we reached the end of this video in this
one we solved the course schedule
problem with two different ways i hope
that you understood them both and see
you in the next one
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the key
permutation problem
with the range of numbers from one to n
inclusive we can make n factorial
permutations by labeling them in order
starting from 1 you're asked to return
the kit permutation
for example with n equal to 3 and k
equal to 3 here are the 3 factorial
permutations of 1 2 3 labeled and in
order
case three so i'll return the third one
two one three
the first solution that may come in your
mind is obviously the brute force
solution generating all the permutations
then return the kth1
we give to the function of the range
from 1 to n inclusive then we return the
one at index k minus 1. remember that an
array is 0 indexed so the kth one is at
index k minus 1.
but the problem with the solution is
that with n elements we can make n
factorial permutations of length n and
it costs n times n factorial to generate
them we get an off m times n factorial
time complexity solution which is
extremely slow
we deduce that the trick to solve this
problem is to be able to find the kth
permutation without generating the
permutations and this is what we'll see
now
let's take n equal to 4. now take a
paper or notepad software list all the
permutations of 1 2 3 4 in order and
tell me what do you notice i want you to
take some minutes to analyze the
structure of those permutations
here are all the permutations we have a
total of 4 factorial permutations 24.
we can notice that these 24 permutations
can be divided into four parts the first
one contains permutations that start
with one the second one contains
permutations that starts with two and so
on
let's suppose that we want to find the
16th permutation k equal to 16.
if we label them starting from 0 it
means that we want to find the
permutation 15 because 16 is when we
label them starting from one
the question now is can we find what
part among these four parts of
permutation 15 will be
the answer is yes by using math
we know that the first part contains
permutations from 0 to 5 in classif the
second one from 6 to 11 inclusive the
third one from 12 to 17 in classif and
the last one from 18 to 23 in classif
to find which one we just divide k by
the length of a part which is 6 in our
case
15 divided by 6 gives 2 so the
permutation 15 won't be in the part 0
won't be in the part 1 but it will be in
the part 2.
now that we're working with zero index
labeling
we know that the part two contains
permutations that starts with three so
we already know that our kth permutation
will start with three and it will be one
of these permutations
let's continue what's going to happen
now is that the search space will be
reduced now we know that our k
permutation will be in these six
permutations we need to update variables
k needs to be modified initially we were
searching for permutation 15 among all
the permutations but in this group of 6
permutations we're searching for
permutation 3
y3 because 15 models 6 the length of the
pot is 3.
k is 15 when we start from permutation
zero but in this particular part if we
label permutation starting from zero
we're searching for permutation three
and also represents the number of
remaining elements of the permutation
defined and we found 1 so we decrement
and becomes 3.
and factorial also changes it becomes 3
factorial 6.
same thing for path length it also gets
updated 6 divided by 3 is 2.
we also remove 3 from unused elements
because we already found its place in
the permutation and our permutation
doesn't contain duplicates
we can divide these six permutations
into three parts of two elements the
first part contains permutations whose
the second element is one the second
part contains permutations hosted second
element is two and the third part
contains permutations whose the third
element is four
1 for all the elements that we didn't
use it in our permutation
case 3 now can we find the part k
permutation belongs to yes once again we
divide by the path length
3 divided by 2 gives one so the kth
permutation will be in part one
and we know that permutations of part
one have to as second element so the
second element of our permutation will
be two
again the search space will be reduced
we know that our kth permutation will be
in these two permutations
this is why we update the variables k
gets modified as we did previously it
becomes k model as the length of a part
3 modulus 2 gives 1. it means that among
these two permutations we're searching
for permutation 1.
and gets decremented it becomes 2 which
changes the value of n factorial 2
factorial is 2 which also changes the
value part length and factorial divided
by an is 2 divided by 2 which is 1.
we can divide these two permutations
into two parts of one permutation the
first part contains permutations whose
the third element is one and the second
part contains permutations whose the
third element is four
to know the path the kth permutation
belongs to we divide by the path length
the path length here is one and one
divided by one gives one our permutation
will be in part one
permutations of part one have four other
third element so the third element of
our permutation will be four
we'd use the search space we know that
our permutation will be in this part of
one permutation we update variables k
becomes k models the part length one
modulus one is zero n becomes one and
factorial becomes one path length
becomes one and we remove four from and
use elements
we divide this one permutation into one
part of one permutation the first part
will contain permutations hose one is
the fourth element
the length of a part is one and k
divided by one gives zero so our kth
permutation will be in part zero
and permutations of part z will have one
as fourth element so the fourth element
of our permutation will be one
now n becomes zero and it gets
decremented so we finish the process the
case permutation is 3 2 4 1. we found it
without generating all the permutations
if you didn't understand what we've been
doing here let me show it to you in
another way
you first need to understand how our
permutations generated at the beginning
we have n choices for this example
and because we want all the permutations
we try all possibilities when we add one
when we add two when we add three and
one we add four this is why you're
seeing four branches at the beginning
and we're talking about permutations
without repetition so when we take an
element we remove it from possible
choices this is why when we take two at
the beginning for example that branch
creates three branches only not four one
one add one one when we add three and
one when we add four you can see that we
didn't add two again
and when we take four for example we
have two choices left one and three we
get two new branches only
then when we take one of them we have
one choice left the one we didn't take
but in our problem we want to find the
case one the way we solve this problem
is by using math to calculate what
branch we should go from to reach the
combination we're searching for
imagine that you have 1000 books labeled
from 0 to 999
let's say that you're searching for the
book 436
you remember that these books are
organized into 10 boxes of 100 elements
the first one contains books from 0 to
99 the second one from 100 to 199 and so
on
how to know which box to search n you
simply divide the number of the book
you're searching for by the size of a
box because here they have the same size
436 divided by 100 is four we search in
box four
we still didn't find the book but we
reduced the search space
now we will search for book 36 in this
box of 100
why because 436 modulus 100 the pot
length gives 36.
once again the 100 books of the books 4
are organized in 10 boxes of 10 books
each the first one contains books from 0
to 9 after 400s the second one from 10
to 19 after 400s and so on the box size
is 10 36 divided by 10 gives three we
search in box three
in that box three we search for book six
because 36 modulus 10 is six
as the one and so on until we find the
book without traversing all the books
and basically this is what we did to
solve this problem
let's try to generalize at the beginning
we have n k and a news that contains
elements in the range from one to an
inclusive
now while n is greater than zero we
start by calculating the part length
it's n factorial divided by n
after it we calculate the index of the
next element to put in the permutation
remember that we calculated by dividing
k by the path length
after we calculate it we add and use of
either the permutation and we delete it
from unused
we add and use of i because it
represents the common element in the
eighth part
then we decrement n and k becomes k
model as part length to get its new
position in the path that we choose
we keep repeating that and when a
becomes 0 we have our cave permutation
and we solve the problem
in code we have a function that takes us
parameters n and k the given input
we create an empty array for the
permutation we're searching for then we
create unused it contains elements of
the round one to add in clause if
after it to avoid always recalculating n
factorial we create an array fact where
factor of i represents i factorial it
contains n plus one elements to have the
values from zero factorial to n
factorial
to fill it we know that 0 factorial is 1
then for remaining elements we just take
the value of the previous cell and we
multiply it by i
for example with 5 we get 1 1 2 6 24
120.
now we decrement k because k represents
the position of the permutation with one
index labeling but we're working with
zero index labeling so k becomes k minus
one to fit
we're working with zero index labeling
to simplify the math we get the right
result when we divide and use modulus
we can start the loop now
while n is greater than zero part length
is n factorial fact of n divided by n
then the index of the next element to
take is k divided by path length
after getting the index of the next
element which is i we add nudes of i to
our permutation and we delete the
element that index i from unused
before moving to the next permutation we
decrement n and k becomes k model's part
length
after the loop our permutation is built
we just join its elements into a string
and return it we return the kth
permutation as required by the problem
basically the solution we made now uses
math to keep calculating the path that
the kth permutation belongs to because
by knowing it we know what is the next
element to take from unused and use
which is the array of elements we didn't
use yet
for the time complexity creating and use
costs and creating fact array cos n plus
1 and film gate costs n
then the while loop gets repeated while
and is greater than 0 and n gets
recommended at each iteration so the
number of iterations is equal to the
initial value of n
inside it all operations are in of one
except popping the element i from unused
we can have the case where we need to
shift all the elements to the left
and and to join the elements of the
permutation
we have four n plus n squared plus 1 we
get an off n squared time complexity way
better than of n times n factorial of
the first solution
and for the space complexity we have n
for unused and permutation and n plus 1
for fact array
2m plus 1 gives us an of n space
complexity
we reached the end of this video i hope
that you at least understood the general
idea of the second solution which is
dividing the permutations into parts
with a common element and calculating
which part the keith permutation belongs
to
see you in the next lecture
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the minimum window
substring problem
we have two strings s and t and we are
asked to find the shortest substring of
s that contains all characters of t
if such a substring doesn't exist return
the empty string
for example if we have this input as
output we get c e a b e b a is the
shortest substring of s that contains
all characters of t
in other words two a's one b and one c
first of all how can we know that a
string contains all characters of
another one
we can't know it by having the counter
frequencies of each string the one we
use in the valid underground problem
if fracture 1 is the counter of s1 and
fracture the counter of s2 for every
distant character of s2 freck 1 of ch
must be greater than or equal to freck 2
of ch in other words s1 must have at
least the number of occurrences of ch
and s2
in code we'll write for each ch in
fraction if rack one of c h is smaller
than fraction of c h we return false
after the loop we turn true
knowing this we can already think of a
solution the brute force solution which
hovers all possible substrings of s
while keeping track of the shortest one
that has all characters of t
in code we can add an early exit
condition if t is longer than s we can't
find a substring that satisfies the
condition there isn't enough characters
we darkly return the empty string
same result when t is empty who can
return the empty string because
technically the empty string contains
all the characters of the empty string
else we first create a counter for t to
know the frequency of each character in
it let's name it fracti
we also need the string shortest that
represents the shortest valid substring
that we found until now it initially has
m plus one characters to be sure that it
gets updated as soon as we found the
valid substring
now we start traversing substrings of s
to do so we start by traversing the
lengths because we will start by
traversing substrings of one character
then substrings of two characters and so
on
this is why length goes from one to an
inclusive
inside it which are very starting
positions because with the same length
we have the substring that starts at
index 0 the one that starts at index 1
and so on
but oh it doesn't go until the end to
avoid going out of bounds when adding
the length i goes from 0 to n minus
length inclusive
we have the starting position which is i
we have the length of the actual
substring so we can extract it the
actual substring is the one between iron
classif and i plus length exclusive
now that we got the substring we'll
create a counter for it let's name it
frack s
after it we check if the actual
substring replaces the shortest one we
found until now for that two conditions
the actual substring must contain all
characters of t we can't know it with
the function we made
and it must be shorter than the actual
shortest one
the length of the actual substring is
length so if length is smaller than
length of shortest we replace shortest
becomes the substring
after the loop we don't directly return
shortest because it's possible that we
didn't find any substring that contains
all characters of t
to know that we check the length of
shortest if it's still n plus 1 it means
that it didn't get updated we return the
empty string as required by the problem
else return shortest
basically we return shortest when its
length is at most n
[Music]
for the time complexity let's say that n
and m are lengths of s and t
respectively we have m4 building frac t
and m plus 1 for creating shortest
then we have any iterations for the
outer loop and minus length plus 1
iterations for the inner loop and inside
it the cost of extracting the substring
and generating the counter depends on
length
we also have the cost of checking if it
contains all characters which is am
because in the function which are versus
characters of rack t their number is at
most m
we get this sum which is equal to one
divided by six times n times n plus one
times three m plus two n plus four
we simplify and in the worst case t is
shorter than s so m is smaller than n we
get an o of n cubed time complexity
and for the space complexity we have m4
freck t m plus one for shortest and for
sub and n for freck s
we'll get three n plus m plus one which
gives an off and plus amp space
complexity
this solution is obviously very slow
it's not the best one this is why we
will move to the second solution
inside the inner loop we have a cost of
length to extract a cost of length to
generate the counter and cost of amp to
check if it contains all characters
what if we try to reduce this cost to o
of 1 to get a constant cost per in a
loop iteration
follow me well how can we extract the
substring in of one
in reality we won't need to extract the
substring in our second solution we will
just work with the start and end indexes
of the substring which are i and i plus
length we already know them
second thing how can we generate the
counter of the actual substring in o 1
the trick is to not always build the
counter again we will use the one of the
previous substring let me show you how
imagine that we have this string s a b c
a d e c e b a c
and the first substring of five
characters has this counter two a's one
b one c and one d
starting from this counter how can we
get the counter of the next substring of
5 characters which is this one
to do so we just decrement the number of
occurrences of the character that went
out of the window and increment the
number of occurrences of the character
that went in the window
the one that went out is a it was in the
first substring but not in the second
with decrement fracks of a
it becomes one
and the one that went in is e it's in
the second substring but not in the
first one we increment for x of e
it becomes one
and we got the new counter in of one
because no matter the length of the
substring we need to work on two
characters only the one that went out
and the one that went in
there will always be only two because
we're moving by one position at a time
then for the next substring same logic
the one that went out is b so we
decrement for x of b
and the one that went into c so
increment for x of c
and the process continues like that for
all substrings of length 5.
the technique we're using here is called
sliding window in our example we were
using a window of length 5.
then to move to the next substring we
don't start again from the beginning we
just move the window by performing the
necessary changes
and we just focus on what went out of
the window and what entered not what's
inside because it won't change
last thing to optimize the cost of
checking if it contains all characters
the cost is actually m because we need
to traverse characters of recti
but let me show you how to optimize it
in our example t is a b c a it has three
distinct characters a b and c so we have
three conditions to respect to say that
our substring contains all characters of
t
the conditions are at least two
occurrences of a at least one occurrence
of b and at least one occurrence of c
the idea to avoid always traversing all
the characters which can cause m is to
keep track of how many conditions are
satisfied
and if for the actual substring the
number of satisfied conditions is equal
to the length of recti which is a number
of distinct characters of t
then the actual substring contains all
characters of t it's a valid one
okay but some characters are going out
of the window and some of them are
entering which means that when moving
the window some satisfied conditions can
become unsatisfied and vice versa some
unsatisfied conditions can become
satisfied how to handle that
to do so after incrementing the number
of occurrences of the character that
went in
if it's in fracti and freckels of went
in becomes equal to fraction in it means
that we didn't have enough occurrences
of the character that went in and now we
do so when new condition is satisfied we
increment satisfied
and before decrementing the number of
occurrences of the character that went
out if it's in fact t and freck ass of
went out is equal to fracture went out
it means that we had enough occurrences
of the character that went out but after
decrementing we won't because frack as
of went out will be smaller than what's
required this is why with dickerman
satisfied a condition that was satisfied
before is not satisfied anymore
and we decrement fraction of one out
obviously
for example here we have these strings s
and t and we're at this window of seven
characters the conditions are at least
two occurrences of a at least one
occurrence of b and at least one
occurrence of c
here we have one occurrence of a two
occurrences of b and one occurrence of c
only two conditions are satisfied not
enough
let's move the window now e went out but
we don't care because it's not a
character of t
we decrementing frags but nothing
happens
and a went in we increment for x of a
and it becomes equal to fraction of a we
satisfy the new condition
the number of conditions is equal to
length of recti so this substring is
valid it contains all characters of rack
t all conditions are satisfied
we move the window
now c went out of the window and its
number of occurrences in the substring
is equal to the number of occurrences in
t so when we decrement because it went
out the condition becomes unsatisfied we
don't have enough c's anymore
and d enters the window but we don't
care it's not a character of t
now the number of satisfied conditions
is smaller than what's required this
substring doesn't contain all characters
of t
and the process continues like that
once again no matter the length of the
window we're dealing with two characters
only the one that went in and the one
that went out so checking if the actual
substring is valid cos of one
we've been able to optimize extracting
the substring generating the counter and
checking if the substring is valid we've
seen how to do all these in of one
but we didn't see the code yet let's
move to the code
we keep the same early exit condition we
generate the counter of t but now we
don't save the shortest string itself we
just save its start and end position
initially shortest starts as a string of
n plus one characters so initialize
start and end at zero and n plus one
respectively
now we start traversing lengths
what we were doing in the example is to
update frags according to characters
that went in and out compared to the
previous position of the window but to
do so we first need an initial window
that starts at 0 and whose the length is
length and we traverse it normally to
fill frags and count the number of
satisfied conditions
we create fracs and we create satisfied
available to keep track of the number of
satisfied conditions
it initially starts at 0 because we
didn't start traversing characters of s
yet we didn't satisfy any condition
then we traverse characters of the first
window
for each character ch we increment for x
of ch and if ch is a character of t and
fraction of ch becomes equal to fraction
of ch then the number of occurrences of
ch became enough a new condition is
satisfied we increment satisfied
after processing the first window we
check if it's a valid substring before
moving to other ones and if it should
replace the actual shortest one
if satisfied is equal to length of reg t
the number of conditions and length is
smaller than the length of the actual
shortest substring which is n minus
start we replace start and end becomes
zero and length respectively the
boundaries of the first window
now we can start traversing other
substrings of the same length
i starts at 1 and not 0 because the
first substring which is the first
window is already processed
we start from the second one
we want to work with the character that
went out of the window and the one that
went in
but where are them
the actual substring is between indexes
i and classified and i plus length
exclusive
the character that went out comes just
before the window so its index is i
minus one
and the one that went in is the last
character of the window its index is i
plus length minus one
we can start working the character that
entered the window is at position i plus
length minus one so increment fraction
of s of i plus length minus one
now if it's a character of t and its
number of occurrences in the substring
became equal to the number in t it means
that a new condition is satisfied
we write if s of i plus length minus 1
in fact t and frax of s of i plus length
minus 1 is equal to frac t of s of i
plus length minus 1 we increment
satisfied
after it we work with the character that
went out the one at index i minus 1.
if it's a character of t and its number
of occurrences and the substring is
equal to its number of occurrences in t
it means that the condition was
satisfied but not anymore because we
will decrement fractions of s of i minus
1 so it will become smaller than
frequency of s of i minus 1. not enough
occurrences of f i minus 1 anymore
we write
if s of i minus 1 in fact t and frax of
s of i minus 1 equal to freak t of s of
i minus 1 we decrement satisfied we lost
the satisfied condition
after it would decrement for x of s of i
minus 1.
now that we know the number of satisfied
conditions by the actual substring the
one between i and i plus length we can
check if it replaces the actual shortest
one we write if satisfied equal to
length of reg t and length is smaller
than n minus thought we will play start
and end by i and i plus length
respectively we found a shorter string
that contains all characters of t
after the loop start and n represent the
boundaries of the shortest substring but
only if we found one
if n minus start is greater than n then
we didn't update start and end we turned
the empty string because we didn't find
any valid substring
else we return the part of s between
start and close if and end exclusive
what about the time complexity we have
m4 building frac t and iterations for
the outer loop then inside it we have
length iterations for the first loop and
minus length iterations for the second
bond and all operations inside the mind
of one plus and for returning the part
of s
length plus n minus length gives n and
we can ignore m we get an o of n square
time complexity
the space complexity doesn't change
you can see that now we've been able to
reduce the time complexity from off n
cube to off n squared isn't enough no we
can do better
when using sliding window we have the
case where the window size is fixed for
example if we have an array of integers
and we are asked to find the key
consecutive elements with the greatest
sum we use a window of size k
we will move it but we won't change its
size because we know that the subarray
we're searching for is of length k
however in our problem we don't know the
size of the shortest substring that
contains all characters this is why we
tried all possible lengths which offers
substrings of length 1 then those of
length 2 and so on
which resulted in an oath and squared
time complexity
but we have another way of manipulating
the window instead of sliding the window
by one position in other words extend it
from the right by one and reduce it from
the left by one what we can do is to
extend it from the right by one
but reduce it from the left by a number
of times that is between 0 and the
length of the window depending on what
we want to do
let's apply to our problem
the idea of the strategy that we're
going to use is to find the shortest
substring that ends up the actual index
of right that respects the condition
which is containing all characters of t
and obviously keeping track of the
shortest one among the mole the one that
will be returned at the end
let's start for the first index we find
an a but no condition is satisfied we
need two a's
next index we find d we don't care about
it
next index we find c a condition is
satisfied
next index f we don't care
next index e we don't care
next index b the second condition is
satisfied but not all of them
next index e we don't care
next index c we have two c's now but a
condition is still missing
next index e we don't care
next index a will now have two a's which
is enough to satisfy the last condition
all conditions are satisfied now it
means that the substring from left to
right in classif is valid
but is it the shortest one that answers
the index right not true because we may
have characters that we don't care about
by characters that we don't care about i
mean characters that we can remove
without breaking the validity of the
actual substring
and these characters are characters that
are not in t at all and characters of t
that are in excess in our substring
for example if we need two c's only and
we have five c's in our substring we can
remove the first three ones to make the
substring shorter while still satisfying
the condition
remember that our goal is to get the
shortest value substring
we cannot remove from the middle because
characters of a substring must be
adjacent and we cannot remove from the
right because we are searching for the
shortest valid substring that ends up
the actual position of right
so we can only remove from the left we
keep removing while the character at
position left is a character we don't
care about
here the character outlet is a it's in t
and it's not in excess we need two a's
and we have exactly two so this one is
important we cannot remove it
we finish removing from the left so the
shortest substring that ends up right is
this one its length is smaller than the
actual shortest one we update
we move to the next position of right
we'll find the b
the one at left is still important so
the shortest one is this one but we
don't update because it's not the global
shortest one
next position we find an e
the character at left is still important
next position we find the b
the character at left is still important
next position we found an a
and here is where things change because
the character at left is not important
anymore the reason behind it is that we
found another a which means that the
character is now in excess we can remove
the first one without breaking the
validity
we'll move a and we decrement its number
of occurrences
let's see if we can continue removing
d is not an important character it's not
in t we'll move it
c is in t but we have more than enough
we have two c's while we need only one
we move and decrement this number of
occurrences f is not in t we remove
e is not in t we remove it
b is in excess we remove it e is not in
t we remove it
c is in t and is not in excess so we
stop removing we found out that the
shortest valid substring that ends at
right is c e a b e b a and its length is
7 smaller than the length of the actual
shortest bond we replace
let's continue we move to the next
position of right
by the way if you're wondering why
aren't we going back to the beginning
when we increment right it's because we
know that characters before the actual
position of left aren't important we
don't need them for the actual substring
we found the d the character at left is
still important and we don't update
because the length is not smaller than
7.
next position we find f the character at
left is still important and we don't
update
next position we find the c which means
that the character at left is not
important anymore the character c is in
excess we can remove it
e is not in t we also remove it a is
important because it's in t and it's not
in excess we stop removing
we get a b e b a d f c which is not
shorter than the actual shortest we
don't update
we continue with on d and a is still
important
next position we find f is still
important next position we find c and a
is still important
basically it will continue like this for
the next five positions and there is no
update because the substring is getting
longer we're not being able to remove
from the left
and in the next position we found an a
so the one at left is not important
anymore we remove it
these in excess we move it e is not in t
we move it
b still in excess we remove it a is not
in excess so we stop the substring is a
d f c d f c b f c b e a
but not short enough to update
i lost index we find d and a still
important
we don't update and we finish traversing
s the global shortest substring that
contains all characters of t is the one
between indexes 7 and 13 inclusive it's
c-e-a-b-e-b-a
take some seconds to process what you've
seen until now before continuing the
video
let's move to the code we keep the same
early exit condition we built fractions
we did previously we initialized start
and and at zero and respectively we
initialize satisfied at zero we create
frags which is empty at the beginning
and we add a variable left that
represents the left boundary of the
window
here n starts at n and not m plus 1
because now and represents the last
index of the window it's inclusive
also you can see that we created frags
and satisfied outside the loop because
we want traverse lengths as we did in
the previous solution we don't need to
do that we will directly traverse
positions of right the right boundary of
the window
for each position right we increment the
number of occurrences of the character
obviously and we check if we satisfy the
condition as we did in the previous
solution if as of right is in fact t and
flex of s of right is equal to fraction
of as of right we satisfy the condition
so increments satisfied
basically in the path before satisfying
all the conditions this is what we need
to do only incrementing the number of
occurrences and checking if we satisfy
the condition remember that we're
expanding from the right only left
remains zero
but once we satisfy all the conditions
which we can verify with this condition
satisfied equal to length of recti we
can start removing from the left
we don't know how many characters are we
gonna remove from the window so we use a
while loop
we said that we keep removing characters
while the character at left isn't
important
and a character that is not important
means that either is not a character of
t or it's in excess means we have more
than what's required we write while as
of left not infractee or fracks of s of
left greater than fraction of s of left
inside the loop we remove the character
which means that we decrement its number
of occurrences in fracs and move left to
the next position
now that we removed all unnecessary
characters we go the shortest valid
substring that ends up the actual
position of right is the one between
left and right and claws if
what do we do now we check if it
replaces the actual global shortest pawn
the length of the substring we found now
is right minus left plus one plus one
because this time the right boundary
which is right is included in the window
and the length of the actual global
shortest one is n minus star plus one
plus one for the same reason
so if right minus left plus one is
smaller than n minus star plus 1 we
update start and end become left and
right respectively
after the loop almost same return
statement we just add plus 1 because n
is included in the window now
if we could update at least once we
return the part of s between start and
end in closing else we return the empty
string
by the way you can see that this time we
weren't checking if we lost a satisfied
condition because we stopped removing as
soon as we reach the minimum required
occurrences we never go below it
this is why when the carboxylate left
was important we weren't removing at all
not like in the previous solution where
we were removing no matter
what for the time complexity we have m4
building frag t and the outer loop does
any iterations
it's true that we have an inner while
loop but the tricky part is that its
number of iterations doesn't exceed n in
total i repeat in total
why simply because at each iteration of
the while loop we're removing a
character and we have n characters
remaining operations are all of one so
the cost of the outer loop isn't of n
yes o if and only not more
we add plus n for extracting the output
and in total we have m plus of n plus n
which gives an o of m plus m times
complexity better than of n squared
and for the space complexity same as the
previous solution of m plus m
and we've been able to solve the problem
in all of m m time only by using a bunch
of interesting optimizations
that was a tough problem i hope that you
understood how we built our optimized
solution now that you will be able to
use it to solve all the problems
we've reached the end of this video it
was a long one but i try to detail each
operation to let you understand what is
each line of code doing and how the
algorithm works in general see you in
the next video
welcome back to the course in this
lecture we will solve the largest
rectangle in histogram problem
we are given an array height that
contains the height of each part in the
histogram and we are asked to return the
area of the largest rectangle in the
histogram
note that each bar has a width of 1.
for example if we have this input here
is the largest rectangle its area is 7
times 5 which gives 35.
how can we solve this problem let's for
example take this bar it has a height of
2.
now can you tell me what's the largest
rectangle of height 2 that passes from
this bar is this one
but how did we know
let's start from that bar and keep
expanding
can we expand to the left yes 3 is
greater can we expand no because we have
no more bars on the left
from the right now can we expand yes 4
is greater can we expand yes 5 is
greater than 2 in other words this part
is higher so our rectangle can pass from
it
can we expand yes 7 is greater can we
expand yes 6 is greater can we expand no
we can't expand from here because 1 is
smaller than 2 so if we expand the
rectangle won't be fully included in the
histogram it's not a valid rectangle
we expanded as much as possible from
both sides we got the largest rectangle
that passes the initial bar is this one
it has an area of 12 2 times 6 the
height multiplied by the width
and we can apply the strategy on each
bar while keeping track of the greatest
area at the end we will have found the
greatest area because the largest
rectangle necessarily passes from a bar
that has the same height as itself
the reason behind it is that if the
rectangle is shorter than all the bars
it passes from it means that it's not
the largest one you can still make it
bigger by increasing its height
and if it's taller than at least one bar
the one is not fully included in the
histogram it's not a valid rectangle
with this example with the first bar we
get this rectangle with the second bar
we get this rectangle and so on
at the end the greatest area that we
find is 35 the area of this rectangle
in code we initialize max area to zero
because we didn't traverse any rectangle
yet then for each bar i we expand from
both sides
from each side we keep expanding while
the bar is still higher or as high as
our bar so we stop when we find the
shorter one or when we have no more bars
left starts at the actual position then
while the previous part exists and is at
least as high as the actual bar we
expand we move left by one position to
the left
same logic with the right side but by
incrementing
right starts at i then while the next
part exists and is at least as high as
the actual bar we expand we move right
by one position to the right
while right plus one smaller than n and
heights of right plus one greater than
or equal to heights of i we increment
right to take it to the right
now that we know boundaries of our
rectangle we need to calculate its area
the area of a rectangle is the height
multiplied by the width the height here
is the height of the initial bar height
of i
and for the width is the distance
between left and right plus one
right minus left plus one plus one
because both left and right are included
in the rectangle
now we check if we replace max area
becomes the max between its actual value
and the area of the actual rectangle
heights of i multiplied by right minus
left plus one
after the loop we just return max area
for the time complexity we're traversing
the n bars and for each bar when
searching for left and right boundaries
we may traverse the whole histogram this
is why we get an o of n square time
complexity in the worst case the worst
case happens when all bars have the same
height
and for the space complexity it's
constant we're just using 8 variables
this solution is slow let's move to the
next one
there are interesting properties to know
about the shortest bar the first one is
that by starting to make a rectangle
from it we can expand it until the
boundaries of the histogram because
there are no shorter ball to stop the
expansion
second one the rectangle starting from
any other bar can't pass through it
except if it has the same height but we
get the same rectangle in that case
so the shortest part is like a wall any
other rectangle will either be on his
left side or on his right side
from these two information we can make a
solution based on divide and conquer
we search for the shortest bar and we
have a rectangle that traverses the
whole histogram
we also recursively search for the
largest rectangle in the left side the
largest rectangle in the right side and
we take the maximum among these three
rectangles it represents the largest
rectangle in the whole histogram
the reason behind it is that because our
bar is the shortest one we can't have a
taller rectangle that joins the left and
the right side a taller rectangle will
either be in the left part or in the
right part so we don't worry about
missing a larger rectangle we can search
in each side separately
we also consider the rectangle whose the
height is the height of the shortest bar
the one that traverses the whole
histogram because it's possible for it
to be the largest one
even if it has the smallest height but
its width can make it the most
interesting rectangle
in code we create a recursive function
that takes as parameters the array of
heights but also low and high the
boundaries of the part of the histogram
we're searching in right now
at the beginning we search in the whole
histogram so low and high will be
initialized to the index of the first
and the last power
the first base case is when the actual
part is empty when low exceeds right we
just return zero we have no rectangle
second base case when we have only one
bar when low is equal to high in that
case we just return the height of that
bar
else we have the recursive case we start
by calculating the position of the
shortest bar in the actual part
for that we calculate the smallest
height in the actual part between low
and high and closer then we switch for
its index in the actual part again
now that we have it we recursively
search for the greatest area in the left
and right sides
for the left part we put postmen minus
one as the right boundary and for the
right part we put postmen plus one as
the left boundary
and for that short but wide rectangle
its height is the minimum height we
calculated before and its width is the
whole part we are searching in high
minus low plus one
so we return the maximum between from
left from right and min h times high
minus low plus one this one represents
the area of the short but wide rectangle
we also need a non-recursive function to
call this one the initial values of low
and high are 0 and n minus 1 the index
of the first and last bar respectively
for the time complexity in the best case
the shortest bar is always in the middle
so in recursive cases we divide the
input size by 2.
we have and four searching for the min
and two times t of n by two for cursive
calls we got t of n is equal to two
times two of and divided by two plus n
by using the master method this requires
relation gives off analog and time
complexity
but in the worst case the shortest bar
is always the first or the last bar
for example when is the first one from
the left the input size becomes zero we
get t of zero but from the right the
input size becomes n minus one we get t
of n minus one
plus n two so it for the minimum we get
t of n is equal to t of n minus one plus
n
and if we keep replacing this recurrence
relation gives off n square time
complexity same as the previous solution
it's like we did nothing
what's slowing down the process is
finding the minimum its cost is n to
search for the minimum in the range
we're searching for
but we can optimize this by using a
segment tree for example we can reduce
the cost of searching for the minimum in
the range to log n
the recurrence relation becomes t of n
is equal to t of n minus one plus log n
we get off unlock n
plus and to build the segment tree we
get an off analog and time complexity
better than of n squared
but we still have two solutions to
discover
the strategy we used in our first
solution is that for each bar we search
for the next shorter bar from the left
the next shorted bar from the right and
we calculate the area of the rectangle
but always traversing bars again to
search resulted in an off n-squared time
complexity
what if we can traverse the histogram
only once to find the next shorter part
of each bar yes it's possible by using a
stack
we can maintain a stack in an increasing
order for example we have 2 4 7 8 then
we want to insert 5 but it wouldn't be
increasing anymore so we keep popping
until we find a smaller element
and we push it remains increasing
then again we have 6 9 10 12 then to
insert 8 we'll pop 12 we'll pop 10 whip
up 9 and we insert
and so on
and we can use this principle for our
problem we work with heights
we maintain a stack and to find the next
shorter bar from the left of the actual
bar we keep popping until the top of the
stack becomes shorter
after it we also push the actual bar for
the next iterations
let me show you how it works with our
example
we can add two bars of height -1 at
extremities to avoid having an empty
stack
-1 to be sure that they will be shorted
at any bar
at the beginning the stock contains the
bar 0 and we start from bar 1.
the top of the stack is shorter we
already found the next shorter it's at
index 0.
and we'll push the actual bar
next index the top of the stack is
higher we pop
now it's smaller the index of the next
shorter is zero and we'll push the
actual bar
next bar top of the stack is shorter we
already found
next router is the part index 2 and we
push the actual one
next bar same thing top of the stack is
shorter
next bar same thing
next bar whip up once and we find it
next bar we have to pop all of them
except the last one because they are all
higher
next par the top of the stack is already
shorter its index is seven
next bar i'll read it shorter
and it continues like this for the whole
histogram
now we got the index of next router bar
from the left of each bar but we still
need the one from the right so we can
apply the same process but from the
right
the stack now initially contains the
rightmost bar the one we added from
there hose the height is minus one
first path from the right the top is our
ready shorter and we push
next bar we pop once and we find the
index we also push
next bar already shorter we write and we
push
next par same thing we'll write and we
push next bar same thing
next bar same thing
next bar will pop twice we write and we
push
next bar we pop once we write and we
push
next bar we pop thrice we'll write and
we push
and the process continues like that
now for each bar we have the index of
the next shorter bar from the left the
index of the next shorter bar from the
right we can calculate the largest
rectangle that passes from the actual
bar
for example for this one next shorter
bar from the left is 0 from the right
hit 7 so we get this rectangle
to get the largest one in the whole
histogram we traverse largest rectangle
of each bar while keeping track of the
global largest one as we did in the
first solution but we don't need to
search again here
and we've been able to solve the problem
by traversing the histogram only thrice
instead of n times which will reduce our
time complexity to o of n
[Music]
in code we first add those two bars of
height minus one at extremities
then we create an array from left where
from left of i represents the index of
the next router bar from the left of the
bar i
we also create a stack that initially
contains the first bar the one we added
now for each bar except once at
extremities we keep popping while the
bar on top of the stack is higher or as
high as the actual bar
we write wild heights of stock of -1
greater than or equal to heights of i
will pop
stark of minus 1 represents the top
element
after the loop the next shorter bar from
the left is on top of the stack we
assign it to from left of i we also push
the index of the actual bar i
we finished filling from left we will do
the same thing from the right we create
from right we initialize the stack by
putting the last bar only and we start
now we traverse bars but in the reverse
order remember that we start from the
right and we move
same logic for what's inside the loop
but we assign to from right of i now
after having both arrays filled we can
start working we initialize max area to
0 then for each bar we check if we
replace max ariel
max area becomes the maximum between its
actual value and the area of the
rectangle of the actual bar
the height of the actual bar is height
of i and the width is from right of i
minus from left of i minus one minus one
because the next shorter bars are not
included in the rectangle we don't count
their width
so
the area is height of i times from right
of i minus from left of i minus 1
after the loop we return max area
for the time complexity we have n to add
those bars and integrate from left and
now for the loop it's true that we have
a nested while loop where the total
number of iterations won't exceed n
because each bar is pushed and popped
only once and we have n bars so the cost
is n
same logic for the process from right
and we add and to search for max area
we get an off and time complexity
and for the space complexity we have n
for heights and for the stack and for
from left and and for from right we get
an off and space complexity
in this solution whichever is the
histogram thrice but we have a solution
where we traverse it only once let's
talk about it
okay imagine that we have this bar as a
first bar we can still expand it from
the right because we didn't find the
shorter one
the next bar is this one we can still
expand them both we found nothing that
stops them third bar same thing
fourth bar same thing
we can still expand them all because the
heights are increasing
and we're putting them in a stock by the
way
but for example the next bar is this one
this bar will let the previous three
bars stop expanding because it's shorter
than them in other words all bars that
are taller than it in the stack
and because now we know where these bars
stop we can calculate their largest
rectangle
the actual bar is at index 4 so they
stop at index 3.
for this bar here is the rectangle for
the next one in the stack here is the
rectangle
and for the next one here is the
rectangle
we stop popping because the top of the
stack is shorter so it can still expand
you can see that what we're doing is
that we're pushing our bars onto a stack
then when we found the next shorter bar
from the right we know where they stop
we calculate the rectangle
now we push this bar and we continue
this bar is higher we have nothing to
pop we darkly push it
but for this one it's shorter so we pop
this one and we calculate the rectangle
the top is still taller we pop and we
calculate the rectangle
but wait with this bar the largest
rectangle that we can make is not this
one is this one
the reason behind this wrong result is
that the index of a bar is not
necessarily from where its largest
rectangle starts
in reality its largest rectangle starts
from where the last popped bar that
iteration starts for example for this
one remember that we'll pop three bars
this one was the last one
it means that the largest rectangle
starts from here this is why when we
push bar we keep the same height but as
index we put the index where the
rectangle of the lost popped bar starts
let's work with the greater example the
one we've been working with in this
video
we can add those two bars of height
minus one extremities to avoid having an
empty stack
first part the bar on top is shorter we
darkly put it on the stack
next bar the bar on top of the stack is
taller so we found the end of its
rectangle its i minus 1.
the top of the stack is not small
anymore we stop popping
but now when we push this bar as height
we put 2 but as index we put the index
of the last popped bar which is 1.
let's continue for installer we just
push with its index because we didn't
pop anything
next bar same thing next bar same thing
next bar we need to pop
and we found the end of this bar here is
its rectangle
and when we push 6 as index we put 5
next part we need to pop
here is the largest rectangle of the
popped bar its beginning is the index we
pushed and its end is i minus 1. we can
calculate the rectangle and see if it
replaces
top is still higher we pop top is still
higher we pop top is still higher we pop
you can see that for each popped bar we
can easily find its largest rectangle
top is not higher anymore we stop
and the starting index of the last pop
node is 1 so we put an index of 1 when
pushing the actual bar the reason behind
it is that from the left our bar can
extend until the index 1. from the right
we don't know yet
next bar higher with darkly push
next bar same thing
and the process continues like this
until the end
after finishing we found that the
largest rectangle is this one return its
area
and we've been able to solve the problem
by traversing the histogram only once
in code we start by adding those bars at
extremities we create max area we create
a stack and we start traversing bars
the stack initially contains the first
bar the one that we added and you can
see that now we're storing both the
index and the height
in the previous solution we stored the
index only because we could calculate
the height from the height array but
this time the pushed index is not
necessarily the one where the bar is in
the histogram so i will start both
and this time we need to traverse the
bar the right extremity to empty the
stack to calculate rectangles of bars
that are still in the stack
so i start from 1 and goes until the
last bar
at each bar i we need a variable start
that indicates from where the largest
rectangle of the bar i starts
remember that is the starting index of
the last bar we popped
but we didn't start popping yet so we
set it to i
now we start popping
while the bar at the top of the stack is
higher or as high as the bar i we pop we
put the index and the height in two
variables
remember that we need to calculate the
largest rectangle of the popped bar its
height is the pushed height its start
index is the pushed index and its end
index is i minus 1 so its width is i
minus 1 minus top index plus 1 which is
i minus top index
we check if it replaces max area max
area becomes max between its actual
value and top height times i minus top
index
and we're searching for the start index
of the last popped bar so start receive
stop index
after the loop start now holds the start
index of the last popped bar and the
height of the actual bar is height of i
we push start height of i
and after the outer loop we return max
area that's it
for the time complexity once again the
inner while loop will do at most any
iterations in total because each bar is
pushed and popped only once we get an
off and time complexity
and for the space complexity off and
because of the stack and height array
we've reached the end of this video in
this one we've seen different solutions
to this problem i hope that you
understood them all and that was the
last problem of this course
congratulations for finishing this
course i hope that you learned a lot of
new things from it and will be able to
apply them in other situations
to learn even more you can check the
other courses i made like the 50 popular
coding interview problems course check
the links below
also please tell me what you thought
about this course if it's good if it's
bad what should be improved etc
see you in another occasion